Who doesn’t love their pets, right?
Whether it’s a dog, a cat, a goldfish, or
a hamster, any pet owner will tell you that
their furry friend is so much more than just
an animal that they adopted.
To many, pets become permanent additions to
the family; while they might not look like
a human being, or even have the ability to
speak the way we do, a lot of owners view
their pets as people in their own right.
Of course, a person can’t be a pet, at least
a human person can’t, right?
Well, not unless you happen to be part of
SCP-1897, otherwise known as the Human Domestication
Society.
If you’ve ever been brave enough to travel
alone to the rural parts of southwestern states
like Arizona, New Mexico, Texas, Oklahoma,
Utah, or Nevada, then it’s likely you would’ve
been an ideal victim for SCP-1897.
This designation doesn’t refer to one single
creature or entity, but rather a group of
similar beings.
Witness testimonies and photographs of SCP-1897
depict them as humanoid creatures, standing
approximately five meters in height.
These beings have displayed speed and strength
far beyond that of any human, they are capable
of traveling roughly two hundred meters in
only nine seconds, and lifting weights of
up to five hundred kilos with a single hand.
These entities are not immortal and can be
harmed by conventional means, but that doesn’t
mean it’s an easy task.
Any SCP-1897 instance that is killed or incapacitated
immediately vanishes, resulting in them dropping
anything that they may have been carrying
at the time.
And surprisingly, these are not mindless monsters,
and actually appear to be capable of communication.
Furthermore, they do not seem to speak a unique
or distinct language but instead communicate
in standard American English, with accents
and vernacular appropriate to the regions
they appear in.
However, they will actively refuse to reply
to any human that attempts to engage them
in conversation.
Now, these creatures don’t spend every waking
hour of the day roaming around the states
of Texas, Oklahoma, and all the others we
listed.
If they did, it’s likely a lot more civilians
would have spotted them by now, and would
probably live their lives in fear of these
gigantic five-meter-tall humanoids.
But instances of SCP-1897 will only manifest
if certain specific criteria are met, and
these are as follows.
To encounter SCP-1897, a person must be alone,
or part of a group of no more than two.
If more than one other person is with them,
then no manifestation will occur.
There is one exception to the rule: If a child
under the age of twelve is present.
Secondly, neither the person nor anyone with
them can be carrying any kind of weapon - that
means no knives, no guns, not even pepper
spray.
Third and finally, they must be at least twenty-five
meters from a major population center.
And what happens when all of these conditions
are met and one of these creatures appears?
Anyone witnessing their arrival will notice
the creatures materializing, appearing to
emerge from some form of unseen vehicle.
When they manifest, the SCP-1897 entities
are almost always carrying long poles with
large nets at the end, as well as steel cages,
and are often seen wearing dark green uniforms.
In most cases, they will attempt to capture
any nearby person, in a way that causes them
the least possible harm.
Should an SCP-1897 creature successfully apprehend
a person and place them in a cage, both them
and their captive will vanish in a similar
manner to the way the creature appeared.
All attempts to track SCP-1897 or one of its
abducted victims have failed; there is no
way to know where they are taken.
But as far as what happens to them?
That, we do have a little more insight into.
Sometimes, although it is a highly rare occurrence,
the captured human victims may reappear around
a month after their capture.
While never in the same location as where
they disappeared from, they will always be
accompanied by an SCP-1987 instance and will
stay close by the creature’s side.
At this point, the abductee is barely human
anymore.
They are considered an instance of what is
known as SCP-1897-1.
What signifies this sudden and drastic transformation?
For one, these victims are always found to
have been forcibly castrated or sterilized,
essentially no longer able to reproduce the
way humans naturally do.
For another, these instances of SCP-1897-1
universally display a decreased level of cognitive
and mental function.
What we mean by that is their brains do not
function the way they should anymore.
Instead, these abductees exhibit the same
level of intelligence and capability as the
average Canis lupus familiaris, otherwise
known as the common domestic dog.
Should someone attempt to rescue a person
that has become an instance of SCP-1897-1,
or display hostility towards the SCP-1897
creature that accompanies them, they will
be met with outward, animalistic aggression
from the victim.
It has been discovered by the SCP Foundation
that these behaviors can be treated with amnestics.
Unfortunately, though, the process of an abducted
person becoming an SCP-1897-1 instance seems
to be the result of an invasive medical procedure
known as a lobotomy.
This typically involves removing or disabling
certain parts of the human brain, meaning
that what has been done to these victims is
permanent, and cannot be reversed.
So, who is doing all this?
Why are these creatures collecting innocent
human beings only to reduce them to little
more than animals?
The answers lie in something currently referred
to as SCP-1897-2; not another creature or
entity, not an anomalous artifact or location
with strange properties, but a website found
at the address ‘www.hdsociety.gov’.
According to the information on this site,
it belongs to a group calling themselves the
Human Domestication Society.
The website features pages such as ‘Adoption’,
‘Training’, ‘Breeding Programs’, ‘Volunteering’
and more.
The fact that this is the kind of website
you might expect to be about dogs or cats
but instead focuses on the domestication of
humans is certainly enough to turn the stomach.
As we said at the start of the video, surely
a human being can’t be somebody’s pet,
right?
Wrong, at least as far as the Human Domestication
Society goes.
Their website contains everything and anything
one of these SCP-1897 creatures could ever
hope to learn about owning a human as a pet.
“Has your human been misbehaving?
Need to train them to use the toilet?
These pages have all the information you need
to help your human become the most well-trained
human on your block!” boasts the Training
page of www.hdsociety.gov.
The remainder of the page contains links to
various articles such as ‘Obedience Training’,
which claims an owner of a human can “show
them who’s boss without the need for physical
violence”.
Also featured are mentions of how to toilet
train or play fetch with a human, how to introduce
a human to others due to them naturally not
getting along.
Perhaps most chilling of all is one article
titled ‘Understanding What Your Human Wants’
that warns human beings shouldn’t talk.
And another, ‘Dealing with Strays’ offers
tips for anyone wanting to capture their own
pets themselves.
It doesn’t seem like too much of a leap
to think that the SCP-1897 creatures have
followed a lot of advice from this particular
article.
Arguably worst of all is an image featured
on the website, of a tall, menacing SCP-1897
entity, brandishing a picana electrical.
This device, for any unfamiliar with that
term, is a form of high voltage electrical
cattle prod, normally used for purposes of
torture.
In the photograph in question, the creature
is wielding one of these while standing sternly
over a helpless captive human male, now an
instance of SCP-1897-1 with tears in his eyes.
Further pages found on www.hdsociety.gov recommend
solutions to certain human behaviors.
For example, like one might expect to find
on other pet care websites, some of the Human
Domestication Society’s articles pertain
to dealing with aggression, grooming, house
training, and even toilet training.
Then there’s the Adoption page, which states
“We offer a large variety of humans for
adoption every single day.
While we cannot guarantee a human you see
listed on our website will be available when
you reach the shelter, our inventory is updated
every half-hour.
We cannot answer any questions about specific
humans pictured on our website over the phone
or email.”
It is still unclear whether or not the SCP-1897
creatures that have been known to appear in
the southwestern United States are sent out
to gather humans en masse to offer for adoption,
or whether these creatures are individuals
trying to obtain human pets on their own.
Of course, the worst conceivable answer is
both.
The site is horrifyingly comprehensive, with
links to an annual human ownership convention
- with panels on breeding and preventing illegal
human poaching and skinning.
It’s safe to say that if ever you were unlucky
enough to read this website, it’d haunt
you for life.
Naturally, the SCP Foundation has made several
attempts to contact the owners of this website.
They tried in vain to communicate through
the official channels about SCP-1897-1 adoption
as a way of peacefully negotiating that the
Human Domestication Society website be shut
down as well as its practices of capturing,
lobotomizing, breeding, and adopting humans.
However, these communication attempts were
met with silence.
That is until a message was received by The
Foundation at Site 06, addressed to a member
of personnel that does not exist.
No data pertaining to the physical location
of the sender could be derived from the email,
but it was traced to the same IP address as
the Human Domestication Society’s website.
The email read as follows: “We will not
listen to your lies any longer.
It was you who came after us first.
You who tore holes in our world and tried
to annihilate us.
You who took our olive branch of peace and
fashioned it into a spear.
You who nearly drove us to extinction.
And now that we have the advantage, you attempt
to patronize us with your crocodile tears.
We will not be deceived again.
“But unlike you, we are not monsters.
We have much anger towards your kind, but
we are willing to forgive.
But first, you must be willing to change.
Slavery and genocide are immoral, and not
even you deserve such a fate.
It is our belief, then, that this alternative
is a fair compromise between guaranteeing
our safety and allowing your kind to live.
This is our mercy to you.
“Look at the humans who have gone through
our program.
See how much happier they are?
Your correspondence tells us that you have
seen them.
Seen how much they love us.
Why, then, do you continue to be defiant?
Someday you will thank us.
Please try to understand that this is for
your own good.”
For now, there is little that the SCP Foundation
can do to prevent the Human Domestication
Society from abducting human beings to sell
as pets to other SCP-1897 creatures.
Civilian access to the hdsociety.gov website
has been restricted, so we recommend you stop
typing into the search bar of your browser
to go take a peek.
Yes, we mean you!
Seriously, stop that!
As for the entities that have appeared in
the rural areas of the southwestern states?
All the Foundation can do is position its
agents nearby, in the hopes that they can
detain and neutralize the SCP-1897s as they
appear, with lethal force if necessary.
At present, the only procedure for any human
pets that are successfully recaptured is to
have them moved safely to containment until
a way of rehabilitating them is found.
So far, there hasn’t been any luck on that
front.
Now go check out “SCP-1337 - The Hitchhiker”
and “Irresistible Pick-up Artist SCP-3512
- The More You Know” for more unforgettably
disturbing anomalies that’ll chill you to
the bone!